>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Grant Harris: My
name's Grant Harris.
I'm Head of the European Reading
Room and thank you all for coming
to the Library of Congress today.
We've got a really,
really large crowd here.
We should have had a larger
room but this is what we have,
so [laughter] thanks
for fitting in here.
And we're pleased to
have Pat Grimsted
to come back and talk to us again.
She talked to us about
three years ago I think
about Nazi-looted materials.
Pat has -- I've known Pat since
1985, maybe 1984, when she came
and did some research in
the European Reading Room.
I know her really has having
compiled a whole shelf worth of book
on archives in the Former Soviet
Union and then materials that came
out or after that in the
Former Soviet Republics.
But she's turned her attention to
other materials now, plundered art
and -- from the Nazi area,
both the art and books.
I should backtrack and say that
Dr. Grimsted is Senior Research
Associate at the Harvard Ukrainian
Research Institute, the Davis Center
for Russian and Eurasian Studies,
and the International Institute
for Social History in Amsterdam.
She is the author or numerous
books and articles on Russian
and Soviet archives and the
founder of ArceoBiblioBase,
and several of you
have used that before.
It's an online guide.
So today it's really more about
displaced cultural treasures
from the Second World War
and restitution issues.
And Pat has written much
about Russia and Ukraine.
But today's talk is in another area.
It's going to be about Minsk in
Belaruse and in the Czech Republic
in the capital city of Prague.
And in both cases it's the national
libraries that are involved there,
large clusters of Nazi-looted books
that are in or near the libraries.
And so that's what we'll
be talking about today.
So, Pat, I'm just going to turn
it over to you at this point.
I should say Pat wanted me
to show some of the materials
that she's been working on --
this article from the International
Journal of Cultural Property .
I told a few of you about this
earlier on this page in the --
just entire article devoted to that.
So I'll pass it around for any of
you who want to take a look at that.
There's also an article
that she wrote about Minsk,
"The Road to Minsk for Western
Trophy Books, Twice-Plundered
but Not Yet Home from the War."
So I'll pass that around as well.
So --
>> Patricia Kennedy
Grimsted: And return from --
>> Grant Harris: And
"Return from Russia."
There are a number of
works concerning Russia.
So, pass those around, too.
Okay. Now I'll turn
this over to you Pat.
And this microphone that I'm holding
leads into the amplifier right there
so people can really hear in the
back of the room, and then the one
in front of you is for the webcast.
>> Patricia Kennedy Grimsted:
Can they get a few more chairs
for our -- I hate to see --
>> Grant Harris: I'll
be trying, yeah.
>> I hate to see people standing.
>> Grant Harris: Yeah, yeah.
We'll see what we can do.
But that's the way it is.
>> Patricia Kennedy Grimsted: Okay.
Well, thank you so much, Grant.
And I am exceedingly grateful for
my longtime friends and colleagues
at the Library of Congress for
inviting me to speak today.
And I'm so gratified that so many
friends and colleagues gathered,
some of whom I've known for decades.
But particularly those that
most recently that I've known
in connection with my work on
displaced cultural treasures
from the Second World War, what
the Russians call displaced.
But I often call them twice seized.
But I started with archives
and then books, but today --
I mean started with archives
and most recently here
at the Library about art.
But today I want to focus on the
long-neglected concentrations
of Nazi-looted books, particularly
with examples in Minsk and Prague.
But before getting to those two
hotspots, as I call them today,
let me back up just a little
bit to explain the background
of how things got to there.
Last October at a colloquium
in Paris sponsored
by the Turgenev Library Association
where I was invited to speak,
I recalled 100,000
books and archives
for the Turgenev Russian Library
in Paris that were plundered
in the fall of 1940,
shipped off to Germany
by the Reichsleiter Rosenberg or
ERR as I will refer to it later,
a special task force initiated
in Paris after the occupation
by Adolph Hitler's
ideological henchman,
Reichsleiter Alfred Rosenberg.
Most of those books from the
BRT, or the Turgenev Library,
went first to Berlin and then
were evacuated to [foreign words],
where they ended the war.
But of those between 6-
and 8000 I've discovered
and they finally admitted
in the year 2000 are
in the former Lenin
Library in Moscow,
which is now the Russian
State Library.
Another 3- to 4000 I have
discovered were in Minsk.
I wrote many of them in the meantime
were intentionally destroyed
as unacceptable for
Soviet libraries.
And others were scattered
throughout the Soviet Union
because they didn't need all
these Russian books from Paris
in the Lenin Library because they
were duplicates of things they had.
And so they used the media
for exchange or sending them
to libraries as far away as
Hellene [assumed spelling]
in Ireland, south of Japan.
But the 3- to 4000, as
I say, are now in Minsk,
divided between the
National Library of Belaruse
and the Presidential Library.
Last year on the anniversary
of, the 70th anniversary
of the Second World War, only 119
of those books have been returned
to Paris of -- that is, of the
100,000, returned to Paris.
And today, to be sure, the Turgenev
Library in Paris is a shadow
of its pre-war glory as the most
significant Russian library abroad.
My monograph on the odyssey of the
Turgenev Library tells that story.
It was published in 2003 by
the International Institute
of Social History, or IISH,
in Amsterdam where I've
been Honorary Fellow,
and that's where my archive, Russian
archive database is now housed.
That institute, together
with its Paris branch,
suffered the largest non-government
wartime loss of books and archives
in the Netherlands, many
of which today remain
in the Russian Federation
and in Belaruse.
The ERR actually took
over the building
of the Amsterdam Institute
on the [foreign words].
My French friend and
colleague, Martine Perla,
author of the prize-winning study
of French libraries during the war,
estimates that 10 million books were
seized from over 2400 individuals
and 400 institutions in France
during wartime German occupation.
A large percentage of
those have never returned
to their home libraries.
While across the continent we now
estimate approximately 12 million
books were transported to the
Soviet Union after the war
as what they call compensation for
the even more millions of books
that were destroyed and plundered
by the ERR and other German agencies
in occupied Soviet lands.
An effort today to try to locate
and account for more of the books
that were looted during the
war and still displaced --
I think there are four
points that I would
like to just emphasize in general.
First, we need to determine
the German agency responsible
for the seizure.
The -- two, the destination
where the books were dispatched,
and their wartime migration
to the extent that's possible.
Three, where the books
ended the war.
And, four, what country
found them after the war?
Because it's the last two
elements that determine the success
or failure of post-war restitution.
Today I emphasize two of
largest concentrations
of still displaced books looted in
Europe by two rival Nazi agencies,
one in Minsk and the
second in Prague.
But let me back up just a few
minutes and tell you a little bit
about how they got there.
The ERR that I mentioned
at the outset only operated
in German-occupied lands
throughout the European continent.
But their rival was the
Reich Security Main Office,
[foreign words], whose looted
library collections in Berlin
by 1943 may well have exceeded
those collected by the ERR.
Those were books seized by both the
[foreign words] and the Gestapo.
But, first, let me just
say a word about the ERR.
I'm currently completing, sponsored
by the Jewish Claims Conference,
an updated and greatly expanded
ERR archival guide which sort
of is a continuation of my
archival reference background.
I think we have this up.
Covering this volume -- it's
only on the Internet, is --
covers remaining ERR and related
archival documents in 10 countries
in 35 repositories as
well as documents hopeful
in trying to trace the ERR loot.
In Western Europe, the ERR was
also responsible for seizure
by the [foreign words] which emptied
an estimated 38,000 homes of Jews
who were deported in Paris alone.
Or either deported or who had fled.
My French colleague, Martine
Perla, as a sequel to her book,
has been posting on a website
thousands of names of individuals
and institutions whose books
were returned after the war based
on French library restitution
records
that have only just
recently been opened.
But in contrast, my point is that
we need to know who took those books
and where they went, and
why they weren't returned
and where they might be today.
And so I've been assisting
the French Committee
on Jewish Archives pretend a new
website with 10 original ERR lists
of priority library seizures,
which is also sponsored
by the Claims Conference
or ERR Project.
I found those lists in
six different archives
in five different countries,
the most important being
in the British Archives,
National Archives [inaudible],
and surprisingly the most complete
one in the Ukrainian State Archives
in [foreign word] which is
how I started with the ERR
because there is the largest batch
of ERR records remaining
anywhere in the world.
And they're now all online thanks
to the help of the Claims Conference
in a project I've been working with.
But the -- from these
French lists of the three --
that are being posted now, three --
they cover perhaps only
300 library seizures.
But these are the priority ones.
And we even have the codes that
the ER used to mark the crates
that they -- with which
they shipped the books.
And what's interesting,
as a colleague
at the Holocaust Museum was pointing
out to me with meetings on Monday,
these are the same codes that they
had for the particular collections
of art that were seized from
the same prominent French
Jewish families.
Why were they seized?
The ERR had a firm
ideological purpose,
and I quote from Rosenberg's
own interrogation at Nuremberg
and his answer, and I quote.
"To organize with the help
from an [foreign word] composed
of political leaders and
experts and from the [inaudible]
of a thorough examination of items
left behind by Jews and Freemasons
that would provide a basis for
future intellectual study necessary
for the political, ideological,
and [inaudible] operations
of both the NSDAP and
the [foreign words]."
Rosenberg's protected [foreign
words], as he called it,
was to become the major post-war
university-level training
and research facility
for the Nazi elite.
The Central Library of the
[foreign words] was operative
in Berlin starting early 1959.
And in 1940, Rosenberg inaugurated
the Institute for Research
on the Jewish question, or IEJ
as we call it, in Frankfurt.
The only [foreign words] institute
that was operating during the war
and the main destination
for Jewish books from Paris.
And then the seizures spread
to the Netherlands and Belgium,
and even Greece, the
Baltic countries, in 1941.
By 1943 IEJ Library
could project a total
of half a million volumes
from all over Europe.
And by the time the end of
the war, we could project
over a million-and-a-half
books and journals that they --
that ended the war in the
town of [foreign word],
70 kilometers northeast of Frankfurt
where the IEJ had their
evacuation center.
However, they'd been forced to
hand over most of the Masonic books
to the [foreign words],
that were [inaudible]
because it was Heinrich
Himmler's offices that won
out for more serious
investigation of the Freemasonry
and the Masonic quote
enemies of the Reich.
Berlin was the second major
destination for books seized
from France and Western Europe.
And most of the ERR library
operations were there during the
first years of the war.
But then the books went in
two different directions.
Those destined for the Central
Library of the [foreign words]
or ZBHS went to Austrian Carinthia
to the Monastery of Tanzenberg
where they ended the
war, about 600,000 books
for the ZBHS from all over Europe.
A year before the planned
invasion of Soviet Union,
ERR also targeted rich East
European immerge holdings in Paris,
including the Turgenev
Library with which I started
to serve their purpose of the --
of research on the
quote "Bolshevik Enemy."
And they set up an [foreign
words] or Eastern Library of --
as part of the anti-Bolshevik
research operations
and its very large
Socialist component
from my institute in Amsterdam.
They took over the building and all
of the library including the library
and archives from the Second
International in Belgium,
all of which are now in Moscow.
After Western bombing captured
books were removed from Berlin,
ordered out of the capital,
most of them to [foreign words]
which by then the Germans had
chopped off from Czechoslovakia.
Major ERR research in library
operations went with the Western --
with the books from Western
Europe, went to the isolated,
or relatively isolated
city of [foreign word].
It's now Polish, in Polish, [foreign
word], 70 kilometers southwest
of [foreign words] or in Polish
[foreign words] in [foreign word].
And thereafter all the ERR
shipments of books from all
over Europe were concentrated
in [foreign word],
including almost two million
volumes seized on the eastern front
that ended the war there.
Restitution after the war -- many of
you may have heard about Offenbach
which was the major concentration
of ERR-plundered books outside
of Frankfurt, and one
of the collecting points
in restitution centers in the
U.S. zone of occupation in Germany
where the Offenbach Archival
Depot, or OAD as it's often called,
or known as [foreign words],
and there were almost one million
volumes that the ERR had sent
to Frankfurt for their IEJ
and all of the millions
from [foreign word]
were brought there.
IEJ, as the antithesis to the ERR,
returned almost 3 million books
to countries from which
they had been looted.
But the second major concentration
of ERR books returned to France
and other countries in the West
were still in this Monastery
of Tanzenberg near [foreign
words], the British zone of --
ended up in the British zone
of occupation in Austria.
And this was where the ERR had
amassed about half-a-million books
for their Central Library
of the [foreign word].
The British captured some
of the ERR staff there.
And forced them to help sort
the books for restitution.
And books were even returned to
the Soviet Union from Tanzenberg,
including 35,000 books from the
former Russian Imperial Palaces
outside of Leningrad
including others
from [foreign words] and Kiev.
Although the Soviets never
admitted that the Americans
or British returned any books or
anything else to the Soviet Union
after the war, and
that's a whole other story
that I've written about
quite extensively.
But the Soviets themselves were
not interested in restitution.
The estimated two or more million
volumes that the ERR had collected
from Western and Southeastern Europe
that ended the war in Ratibor,
Silesia, were not subject
to restitution.
They became part of the lost memory
of the Prussianal [assumed spelling]
and private institutional
libraries from which they had come.
The roads to Ratibor for books
plundered from Western Europe
and the Balkans intersected with the
roads that brought another million
or two plundered books
from occupied Soviet lands.
And that fact that
the roads converged
in the ERR Silesian center
determined their postwar fate.
The Soviet Union, as I say, did not
participate except very symbolically
in Western allied cultural
restitution efforts,
and certainly not from Ratibor.
The Germans, it turned out, had
moved most of the books from Ratibor
to two warehouses on the
railroad line, conveniently,
an industrial suburb
of [foreign word].
I read where it -- that was where
a Red Army Trophy Brigade found 4-
to 5000 German crates
in two warehouses containing an
estimated 1.5 million volumes.
And they used that warehouse
as a collecting point
for additional library materials
that they'd found in Silesia,
many from Belaruse
and Baltic libraries.
And it was those books, in the
millions, indeed, from Belaruse
and the Baltic countries were the
pretext for a shipment to Minsk
in October of 1945,
of 57 freight wagons.
But that was only three or -- one of
the three or four trophy shipments
of books from Silesia
and [inaudible]
to many more from Germany itself.
Those 57 freight wagons,
some people say 54,
transported 1.2 million books.
Over half of them had, in fact,
been looted from Belaruse
and Baltic libraries.
But the other half
million were looted
from Western and Southeastern
Europe.
I first reported details
about the full 1945 shipment
from [foreign word] to Minsk at a
library conference in Minsk in 2003,
which was rather of a sensation
because it had all been suppressed,
of course, during the Soviet period.
I had discovered those
details quite by chance,
as often my discoveries
are, in my book on the --
Turgenev Library from Paris
because the Turgenev Library
had also been found there.
After the conference with
my ERR seizure list in hand,
including the one from Kiev,
I was able to identify 90
individual French libraries
and 10 institutional libraries
with books that had been catalogued
in the Rare Book Department
of what was then the
National Library of Belaruse.
And I think -- this is --
they've since moved to
this fantastic new building
for their National Library
just on the verge of Minsk.
Those books, including
many autographed volumes
with illustrious French
private libraries,
today remain in several
different libraries in Minsk.
For example, I learned
about 5000 books
from the most important pre-1939
private library of Julius Genss
from Estonia of -- it's now in the
Library of the Academy of Science.
I even found a few from former
Russian Imperial Libraries seized
from the Imperial Palaces by
the ERR in suburban Leningrad
that had not been returned to
the Soviet Union or returned
to their home in Leningrad
during the Soviet Union.
I learned that 600 books, in
Armenian, from the Armenian Library
in Paris had been transferred
to [foreign word]
because there was no Armenian censor
in Minsk to approve them for --
to be catalogued in the library.
Some of the Dutch language
books were transferred
to the Library Foreign Literature in
Moscow because there was no censor
in Minsk who could read Dutch.
About half of those that were sent
to Moscow, all right, in 1992,
608 Dutch books were returned to
the Foreign Literature Library.
This was after the fall
of the Soviet Union,
the Russian Federation.
They were returned to Amsterdam
in, from Dutch, from Moscow.
But many more of the
thousands of Dutch books remain
in the capital of Belaruse.
And, coincidentally, the
return to the Netherlands
in 1992 included the
first book returned
to the Turgenev Library in Paris.
Namely Dutch librarians identified
the Turgenev Library stamp
in a Dutch language bible which they
passed on to colleagues in Paris.
All right.
In 2011 the Belaruse National
Library published a CD Rom,
and I'm not sure if it
came to this meeting.
I was showing it yesterday to
the person who handles Belaruse,
one of the colleagues
in the division.
But this CD Rom is entitled
in -- the title is in Russian,
French Autographs in the Holdings
of the National Library of Belaruse.
The CD which was published
displays the title pages of 65 books
from Paris with autograph
dedications
to famous French politicians,
writers, and other cultural leaders,
with images of those individuals.
Those libraries, they found
individuals of all these people.
For example, the full text of --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
-- from Paris, 1933, with a
dedication to the Turgenev Library
by the author and the book
that you saw earlier to --
by Chagall to the Turgenev Library.
To be sure, Belaruse Libraries
are very proud to have
such a valuable collection
of autographed volumes
by such French writers and statesmen
-- Marcel Purse, Luis Vice,
George Clemenceau, Leon
Bloom, among many others,
including numerous members
of the Rothschild clan.
I have a lot of pictures
of the title pages
that I photographed
myself in Minsk in 2003.
Unfortunately, however, when
Russia -- when the Soviet Union --
Russia, should I say, after
-- in 1940 -- or after --
it was in 1956 when the Russian
Federation joined the European Union
-- not the European Union,
the European Council of --
they signed a declaration
with the intent
to send home the trophy possessions
of other European member states.
Obviously, two years later
they passed the law that I --
we were subject to a conference at
Harvard Law School some years ago.
But obviously those
signatures on legal -- of --
they're not really
legal instruments.
They would be soft law as
would be called by the lawyers,
have not been helped bring
home many of the trophy books
and still archives in
Russia, let alone Belaruse.
Other books from the private
libraries of Luis Vice
and Leon Bloom and the Rothschild
clan were returned to France
from OID in Frankfurt
by the U.S. Allies
or from Tanzenberg by the British.
And some of the personal
archives of Luis Vice
and Leon Bloom were returned from
Moscow to France before -- by 19 --
by 2002 and then described
and listed in the book,
Return from Russia that
I think was being passed
around that I prepared with
several Dutch colleagues
and other European colleagues
who had been involved.
But the books with
dedications to those
and other prominent French
individuals, some who perished
in the Holocaust, remain in
Minsk as lost memory for those
to whom they were dedicated.
And now, 70 years later,
lost memory for their heirs.
One can only wonder, as I do, about
the moral justice to treat all
such volumes as compensation
for the millions of books lost
from Belaruse state libraries
in the course of the war.
Let me turn now to the [foreign
words], the security main office
in Berlin where they concentrated
their large collection by 1943.
Many of them were also evacuated.
One large group of Masonic
books were evacuated
to Himmler's favorite Silesian
castle on the [foreign word]
where a Masonic Research Center
continued until January, '44.
Those now -- most of the books
that were there are now in a branch
of the University of
Poznan Library in one
of the [foreign word] castles,
former [foreign word] castles.
And -- not from Poznan
and a microfiche catalog
of that library has been issued.
Following a seminar last fall
in Amsterdam, a Belgian friend
and colleague, Michelle Vermont from
Ghent and Martine Perla from Paris,
and I, are organizing, first,
a workshop in Minsk this
coming September with the help
of a Russian Belaruse historian who
was in Paris last summer where I met
and participated in this colloquium.
And the -- Wesley Fisher who
unfortunately couldn't be
with us today, the Research
Director of the Claims Conference,
is providing funding
for this seminar.
And we've just received formal
invitations for Belaruse visas.
So I think I'll have to come back
here maybe next year and report
if we've made any progress
in Belaruse.
But we're not trying to
talk about restitution.
At the moment we're more
interested in identifying books
and more identifying
particularly because it's come
to light there are a lot of Masonic
archives that remained in Minsk
in some of the cartons of
books they hadn't opened.
But other books remain from
the [foreign words] of --
were evacuated after war or
the last years of the war
to four evacuation castles in
what was then the Sudetenland
and also the concentration camp of
Terezin where they evacuated most
of the Hebraic literature that
they had not been able to catalogue
in Berlin and they forced some of
the illustrious Hebraic scholars
that were interned in Terezin
to catalog the Hebraic
that they had there.
But the castles of --
also in Sudetenland of --
this was the Talmud, what they
called the Talmud Brigade in,
of Terezin itself.
And I -- but there is also a
catalog in one of the castles.
They were preparing a
catalog of occult --
books on occult disciplines.
This is the year of 1944, in
the height of the fighting,
that these people are working
on this occult literature at one
of the castles in -- of Sudetenland,
the castle of Meemon
[assumed spelling] there.
And you'll see next -- I think
the next slide I have the --
well, I'll come back
to that in a minute.
Leave up the map.
It's fine for now.
Some of those -- there were a
million books that were spread
between those four castle and
Terezin by the end of the war.
And I first announced about --
first put together the information
I'd collected about these castles.
I've actually visited all of them
and have pictures and an article
that we -- I think
maybe was passed around.
If not, it's a article
that could be quoted.
And I pieced together this.
And I first published
it, the article --
made a presentation about
these books, the million books
in the castles at a
conference in Liberetz
in the Czech Republic in 2007.
I purposely wanted to do
it in the Czech Republic.
And they actually published my
article in both Czech and in English
in the catalog proceedings.
And I think maybe now in another
office in the division here.
But it may be of some
interest to some of you.
Some of those books were -- for
the research that I was able to do
with the help of some Czech
colleagues, and in German sources --
some of the books were returned
immediately after the war to Poland,
France, Netherlands,
and to Germany even.
Many hundreds of the Jewish books,
an Hebraic from Telecine had
to be destroyed when they
were transported to Prague
because of infectious mold,
that they lacked the facilities
to control after the war.
But the rest of the Jewish
books that survived remain today
and are very well catalogued
by the Jewish Museum in Prague
in a database that has been funded
by the Jewish Claims Conference
with careful identification of
provenance, and they are now --
when they finish this catalogue they
are now -- are planning to return --
and there is a Czech law that
allows them to return these books
to the communities or
individuals, in many cases,
from which the books came.
Some of the books from the
castles were distributed
to various Czech institutions
after the war.
And a local example -- I found,
was shown, a local museum
in [foreign word], if you
still have the map there,
acquired about a hundred books that
had been used for insulation in one
of the castles because they had
no other facilities after the war.
But the vast majority that
they found and had not returned
or restituted after the war
went to a massive warehouse
in a chemical center of
[foreign word] which is
about 30 minutes' drive from Prague.
And during the next half
century they became intermixed
with books confiscated
by the Communist regime
in Czechoslovakia started in 1948
from various museums, monasteries,
Masonic lodges, other places that
were -- that the Communist libraries
and museums did not need,
unneeded, during those years.
So this warehouse came
to [inaudible]
and I hadn't known all
the details about this
until really just last year.
Starting in 2015 the Czech
National Library undertook a project
to catalog these books, and
they received EU funding,
and it turned out to be
mostly Norwegian funding.
Norway's not a member of the EU, but
it makes a contribution every year
which is usually used for
some cultural project.
And the Norwegian contribution
last year was being used
to catalog these books at the
National Library in Prague
that had been relegated to
the warehouse for 70 years.
The Director of the
project contacted me
because he had seen my article that
was written, that was published
in both Czech and English, and
I actually had been in contact
with the Deputy Director
of the Library who,
of the National Library, who
confided to me at one meeting
about 10 years ago
that he had been --
in his first job when he came to the
Library was helping move the books
from the castles in Sudetenland to
this warehouse in [foreign word].
But he didn't know what they
were or where they'd come
from or anything about them.
Since the -- I think we can have
the next picture if you have --
the Director -- I'm afraid
that may not be very readable,
but it's just a little
sample of what I would
like to show about this project.
Last October this Director --
I hadn't met the Director of the
project at the Czech Library,
but he had been in touch with me,
because they were then saying
they only had 300,000 books
in this warehouse.
But he finally agreed to take me
out there when I was going to be
in Prague last October for
an international conference
that was sponsored by another
group in the Czech capital.
And he even set up a very formal
workshop where they were going
to tell me about this project and
tell me where the books came from.
Well, when they gave me
a few minutes to speak,
I showed them pictures
of this catalog that --
or some fragments of the
catalog that I'd found
in the [foreign words] in
Berlin of a 400-page --
the whole fragments counted to be
about 400 pages of this catalog
of occult literature that was
being prepared in one of the --
the castle of Meimon
[assumed spelling].
I -- just before coming to Prague,
I'd given a lecture in Berlin
at the Central and
Regional Library there.
Over the last few years that library
has developed a marvelous database
for what they call [foreign
words] for looted books
that they have found probably
8- to 10,000, that they found
in their library that
had been left in Berlin,
many of them by the
Gestapo or other parts
of the RSS-SHA [assumed spelling].
And they have been
returning them to --
trying to identify and
return them to their owners.
Well, when I was talking to these
librarians I had met actually before
about the project in Prague, I
said, well, let me try to get you --
if you could come a couple of
days early for the conference,
let me try to get you invited also
to this workshop that they've set
up for me at the National
Library in Prague.
And I wrote the Project Director
immediately and he finally agreed.
But when we got there I found out --
he refused to take the
Germans with me to the --
see [foreign word],
to this warehouse.
He said, first he said, that
security provisions were
such that -- hadn't been
arranged far enough in advance,
and that they didn't
have a car big enough.
But when we went to get in the car
that was going to take me there,
there was a minivan right
beside it that didn't look
like it was going anywhere.
But this is -- I also took with
me, was able to arrange to take
at this workshop a Masonic archivist
and library whom I've known now
for probably about 10 years.
And I had helped him in Moscow
where he, over the past few years,
has identified 4- to 5000 Masonic,
looted Masonic archival files
from Norwegian Masonic
lodges that are still in --
that were still with the collection
in Moscow in this special archive
because no one had sorted
them out and they couldn't --
he's been going back and forth and
identified these Norwegian files.
And, finally, they now
have a formal claim
in to the Russian government
for these files.
But, anyway.
He was going to be at
this conference in Prague
and he's been looking for
Norwegian and other Masonic --
it's his specialist --
throughout the Masonic world.
And I asked him to come also, and
particularly that I told him, well,
you know, that the funding for
this project is from Norway.
And so he very quickly looked
in to find out what was going
on because he hadn't known
about the Norwegian sponsorship
for this identification
project in Prague.
But in any case --
>> Ma'am, just one second.
Just five more minutes.
>> Patricia Kennedy
Grimsted: Okay, yeah.
I'm just down to the end.
>> Okay, very good, very good.
>> Patricia Kennedy Grimsted:
Thank you for [laughter] checking.
I've been adlibbing a
little too much in here.
But, in any case, I -- what I --
at this workshop I showed them more
of these [inaudible] because
I had a lot of the fragments,
and he was saying, well, why
didn't you get -- bring his --
can't you give us copies?
I said, I'm sorry, the
[foreign words] charges a lot
of money to copy 400 pages.
And besides, they wouldn't
allow me to give them
to you, a national institution.
You have to ask them yourself.
In any case, the National
Library finished this project.
And you can go on to the
-- yeah, you have it here.
It finished this project
that they were doing.
I, incidentally, got into a
large argument on the drive
out to [foreign words]
with this Project Director
who told me he does not
believe in restitution.
But the Norwegian colleague
-- they did bring us --
they did let us visit the processing
center at their cataloging depot
out -- it's just outside of Prague
where they had brought 7000 books
that were identified
as belonging to --
of individual Freemasons and
anti-Masonic individuals, lodges,
or Masonic libraries, from
-- most of them are German,
but some are from French --
the Benelux countries, Austria,
Hungary, and Czech Masonic books.
The Czech Project Director then was
already announcing no repatriation
will take place.
But when the results of his
trial project were presented
in Prague a month ago my Norwegian
colleague went to the presentation
and he -- it was reported back and
they have now posted this website
on the National Library website
in Prague about the project.
But it's a little -- not quite the
story that I was talking about,
the project, and it says
nothing about the foreign books
that were being catalogued in
the castles in the Sudetenland.
And it mentions my name, but not
my article that I wrote about them.
The day after our meetings at the
National Library I took my German --
I was able also to arrange for my
German and Norwegian friends --
we visited the Jewish
Museum in Prague
where the librarian showed us
a marvelous ongoing project
to identify former owners of
the Jewish books that had come
from these castles in Terezin.
But, to conclude, this morning, just
before I came into the room here
for the talk, I received
another email
from my Norwegian Masonic archivist
friend, and he had just found
for me a picture of the castle
of Meemon that I didn't --
I went to try to see it myself,
but it was destroyed in 1984
by the Czechs because they
said it was going to burn down.
I don't know what the problems were.
But anyway, he sent me some --
a photograph that was taken
just before the destruction,
and also photographs of some of the
foreign books that we had been shown
at this Czech library center in
[foreign word] with ex-libris
and book markings that
he was helping them --
that he had identified just --
we only had about 40 books
there -- from Masonic lodges.
And he could tell almost immediately
which lodge these were from.
And earlier he had told me that
they had a presentation in Norway
about the project about a month ago.
And the Norwegians have
now refused further funding
to continue the project with
the current Project Director.
And in his message this morning,
[foreign words] wrote me,
"To conclude, the project has
ended without any real conclusion.
None of the chosen
13,000 books have been,"
that they've already catalogued,
"have been catalogued properly."
And until that has been done
for the whole consignment,
there's really not much of a
conclusion that can be made."
So, I conclude with that sad note
from Norway, and I'll just --
could remark that I guess I'll have
to come back again in another year
to report about our seminar
in Minsk next September,
and possibly another visit to Prague
to see if they've made any progress.
But then, at least, I don't need to
get a visa for the Czech Republic.
And I do have some other
friends there that will be glad
to see me even if the
library may not be.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> I have a question about the last
point that you made when you said
that your Norwegian friend
had sent you the message
about the project being stopped
because the books that were
to have been catalogued were
not being catalogued properly.
What was the expectation?
How did they expect
the, if you know,
how did they expect the
books to be catalogued?
And in what manner were they
not being catalogued properly?
>> Patricia Kennedy Grimsted: I
don't want to get too technical
with this, and I myself am not
a technical library cataloguer.
But if you come the systems, they
-- database systems, they were using
in the National Library with
the system they were using
in the Jewish Museum in Prague,
you'll see the difference.
They were trying to
register these books.
They had no facility to show the
book markings and the ex-libris
that were in the books
in the catalog.
Whereas in the Jewish Museum,
they've developed that [inaudible].
They had no fields that they
were filling in for the fact
that books had the markings and
what markings those might have been.
It was a project to try to get, just
to get the name and title the way,
a very preliminary
cataloguing basis.
They have the facilities at the
National Library because I know
that they catalogued and have
on their website the
early Hebrew manuscripts
from the Breslow Rabbinical Seminary
that were found there 10 years ago.
They have the facilities
to catalog them properly.
But this man, this head of --
as I say, I had a bit of a in
with him, or an out with him.
But he did send me the
website that I could --
the URL so I could see his
website which is in English.
And if you see that, you'll see the
way they're presenting this project.
They're mainly interested
in the bohemeka [assumed
spelling] that's there,
the books from Bohemia.
But the foreign ones, they'll
try different -- forget the --
my Norwegian friend [inaudible]
wrote me at one point,
this I have not confirmed, and so --
but it's apparent because if you'll
see one of the things on the --
one of the -- at the
top of the website it --
I think there's something for
the legal -- oh, no, it's not.
Later, if you go down another
step, there's something also,
a legal document that has
been translated into English.
And, apparently, what he said
that the library has used some
of the project funding, which is
why they're not being catalogued
properly, for a legal study
to see how the legal basis
that the National Library
can nationalize these books.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Grant Harris: Okay, well, Pat
gave us a lot of information there.
>> Patricia Kennedy
Grimsted: I should --
many of [inaudible]
but I can just say
that I hope I can come
back maybe another time,
and I can tell you a little bit
more about how things are going
in the right -- because what's
[inaudible] these are books,
the books that are being found,
they're not many, maybe not many
of them that still remain from the
occult sciences [inaudible] for yoga
and astrology and what,
whatever that are being found.
But it's very curious when I
saw lists in Paris of the books
that had been returned to France
in 1948 from Prague and they --
the French had lists
in the restitution
records of books returned.
There were a lot of -- many of
them were from occult [inaudible],
the ones that the SD had apparently
taken from French collections
that were about occult sciences.
This also is a -- and
there was a project in one
of the other councils
-- I think I really need
to republish this article that I did
for the Czech conference
with an update now.
And I am hoping to turn some
of my findings into a book
about the lost libraries that
will have some of these details
that have not, simply
not been known.
But I also think that the
issue at the National Library
in the Czech Republic
and I think my --
the Norwegian colleagues
are going to start this.
I think it's something
that should be brought
to the attention of [inaudible].
It's one thing in Minsk
because Belaruse is not a member
of -- maybe they are a member.
Probably are a member of IFLA.
But that's the International
Federation of Library Associations,
the International [inaudible]
of Library Association.
And there have been a very
strong movement in IFLA
about identifying books that
are displaced in foreign --
I mean particularly the valuable
ones and these autographs.
And so I think that there may --
that it should be brought
to the attention.
And I hope some of the people
here at the National --
our National Library, the
Library of Congress, will all --
may also want to take notice
about these types of problems
because it's a -- they're
talking about major collections,
particularly a more major collection
in Minsk than is the case in Prague.
I'm afraid that a lot of the
people aren't going to go
after the witchcraft books.
I even had a email
last week from a woman
who runs a witchcraft
newsletter [laughter] just
because she'd heard there
was 7000 books they found
on witchcraft in one
of these things.
And I assured her, I said, I
think that this is a blowup
that someone wants to criticize
the project from other directions
to say that there [laughter].
But, anyway, that says it.
>> I was just going to say that
those of us who are bibliophiles,
and I must -- most of us in
this room I think are, you know,
value our book as a book if the
binding, the smell, the print,
and so forth -- but it
seems to me in an age
when we're going towards
digitization the most important
thing -- it may not be the book
itself, many of which are 70
or more years old and are
probably deteriorating,
but it may be the information
in them.
And I was going to ask
Pat, how much of this --
you all these books are
in the Minsk Library.
Is the information in these
books somehow available,
maybe in a digital form?
Or do you have to go to
Prague and go to the library
and actually look at the book?
>> Patricia Kennedy Grimsted: Well,
thank you for raising
that question, Jim.
This is very important.
A Belaruse colleague whom I first
met in 2003, when I was in Minsk.
He's now, I think, close to 90.
He had been the Belaruse
SSR, the Soviet Republic
of Belaruse UNESCO
Representative in Paris in,
I think he said the
late '50s or '60s.
And he just said -- told me, he
said, you know, it was very sad
for me when I met the widow of
Leon Bloom or the Luis Vise,
who was a leading feminist,
journalist, in France,
that I couldn't return
or even tell them
that they're books were in Minsk.
He has written some lovely articles,
most of them are in
Russian or Belaruse.
There are a couple in English that
I cite in my article about some
of the relations to the --
the archival, personal archival
information that's in those books.
Because these are books with
very famous French autographs
of leading statesmen
and [inaudible].
And he's done a beautiful job
of showing the dedications,
in some cases to people who perished
in [foreign word] or Auschwitz.
He's done the research on it.
He was a rector of the School
of Linguistics in Prague,
a specialist from French
language and literature.
And he's particularly
researched these books.
And last summer in Paris I met
one and I think that this --
the young historian,
the Belaruse historian,
who now is helping arrange
our seminar in Minsk,
was a student of his because
he spoke very good French.
And I think it was his
first trip outside Belaruse.
But he was on a stipend that a
Paris friend of mine had arranged,
and he gave a lecture at
the Institute of France
about the anti-Dreyfus documents
and manuscripts of several
of the leaders, Jewish leaders, that
were -- about the Dreyfus affair,
because these were books the Nazis
obviously had been trying to capture
from Joseph Reinach and
his family in Paris.
And so this is the kind of
information that is there.
And these were manuscripts from
Joseph Reinach that were --
had never been catalogued
before in --
but Minsk and because
no one wanted them
or they were all suppressed
during the Soviet period.
And he's writing a
doctoral dissertation
about the Masonic manuscripts
that are there.
And it turns out that
they are fragments
of the same Masonic archives that
were returned from Moscow to Paris
by the year 2000 because archives
that were found in Minsk all had
to be sent to Moscow after the
war, but not all the books.
And so they were all collected
in this central repository
for the special archive
that I described
in this book, Return from Russia .
And so these are the
types of materials that --
he's written some lovely -- I just
heard that he is still able to come
and that he's agreed to come to our
seminar next September in Minsk.
We're just keeping it very small,
a mission, that we're trying to --
and I hope to meet him again.
But he has a card file
if sine if the books
that he found particularly
important for the dedications,
for the interpersonal relations
that they show in these dedications
in the books, let alone
the books themselves.
I mean, some of these are
from bibliophile collections
of the Rothschild's
from the 18th century.
I mean they're -- the rare book
department that I had the catalog,
the only books from rare books,
and what are these
books needed in Minsk.
There's no one.
I think this young man that we met
in Paris last summer is
probably the first to --
who even identified
some of the manuscripts,
a collection of Masonic,
of Napoleonic manuscripts,
I think to Napoleonic period,
that are with these materials.
Sorry.
>> Grant Harris: It's time for
[inaudible] cruel time management.
>> Patricia Kennedy Grimsted: Yes.
Okay [laughter].
>> Grant Harris: I have to step in.
So thank you all for coming.
Please help me --
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.